you know you've written a successful
poem
when people really think it happened
dante's divine comedy the author died
700 years ago
isn't this stuff outdated one might
wonder well
not if we still wonder about what dante
wondered about
is the human being capable of
self-destruction
self-delusion self-deception
inferno is the human being in need of
learning how to order
his or her loves in the best way
possible to live as well as possible
purgatory is the will of god something
we can know
is glory real paradiso
if you're like any other human being
you've wondered about these things
these are the questions at the heart of
the divine comedy
how do we build our characters how do we
become
the best people we can become isn't it
by
making difficult choices when pleasure
and pain
are at stake dante did not actually go
on this journey and yet because he can
imagine it
you can see things that are implicit in
everything about us including every
decision
we make and if we master this book then
we can make better choices
this is as much upon about the state of
souls before death
as it is after that it's as much for the
present moment
for the for the real live now as it is
for eternity
if you've never read dante before you
are in the privileged position
i wish i could be you to encounter this
poet for the first time
his intellect his imagination his
understanding his teaching power
it's unforgettable
i'm stephen smith this is our course on
dante's divine comedy
let's begin
you